saludos este es el vídeo número 8 de
química esencial y hablaremos de modelos
atómicos que es un modelo un modelo es
una interpretación o construcción
teórica por lo que existe en nuestra
mente y la usamos para explicar cómo
funciona un fenómeno un fenómeno digamos
por ejemplo la gravedad es casi como una
caja negra no podemos tocarla pero si
podemos desarrollar modelos que nos
ayuden a predecir lo encontremos a un
científico un poco más brillante y
veamos como albert eisntein abordó el
fenómeno de la gravedad lo que hizo fue
tomar modelos que habían sido
desarrollados por isaac newton y pudo
mejorarlos con base en datos que recibió
porque cae una manzana del árbol no es
que una fuerza mágicamente la haya
calado y puesto ahí lo que dijo einstein
es que están deformando el espacio
tiempo y estos objetos viajan usando la
ruta más cercana y la luz viaja
siguiendo la misma ruta y puedo
confirmar esto usando datos
y ahora vemos al átomo veremos que
ocurrió algo similar con el el átomo es
muy pequeño el cuerpo humano tiene 10 a
la 14 células y si vemos una célula
resulta que hay 10 a la 14 átomos en
cada célula
no podemos imaginar que tan pequeño es
un átomo y la cantidad de átomos que
tenemos podemos usar datos para predecir
cómo luce un átomo el modelo de dalton
que eran esferas que se conectaban era
un modelo cuando descubrimos el núcleo
llegamos al modelo de rutherford y luego
usamos el espectro para llegar al modelo
de vor después la física cuántica nos
dio el modelo de mecánica cuántica de
schrödinger así que hemos ido mejorando
nuestra construcción teórica de cómo es
el átomo así que tenemos al átomo que es
un fenómeno luego tenemos un modelo
atómico que es una construcción o
interpretación de cómo pensamos que es
el átomo y luego obtenemos más datos o
información del fenómeno y si coincide
con nuestro modelo todo sigue sin
cambios pero
una vez que la información ya no
coincide con nuestro modelo entonces
debemos desarrollar un nuevo modelo
atómico seguimos recabando datos y
mientras sigan coincidiendo con el nuevo
modelo lo seguiremos usando pero si
dejan de coincidir entonces tendremos
que hacer un nuevo modelo es así como
funciona la ciencia regresando al modelo
atómico
una vez que descubrimos el núcleo del
átomo y los electrones este se volvió a
nuestro modelo la construcción teórica
de cómo lucía el átomo pero una vez que
la información o los datos dejaron de
coincidir cuando obtuvimos información
del espectro que indicaba que los
electrones no se estaban moviendo por
cualquier lado y que estaban confinados
a órbitas entonces llegamos al modelo de
voz y esto nos funcionó hasta que
obtuvimos información sobre la energía
de ionización y la mecánica cuántica que
es cuando desarrollamos el modelo
atómico que usamos actualmente por lo
que mientras la información coincida con
este modelo lo seguiremos usando
ahora veremos como hicimos la transición
del modelo de board al modelo de
mecánica cuántica veamos la energía de
ionización la energía de ionización es
la cantidad de energía que se requiere
para quitar un electrón este es nuestro
modelo tenemos 2 electrones en la
primera capa y tendremos 8 en la
siguiente capa y así sucesivamente la
energía de ionización debería ser así
del hidrógeno al elio funciona bien
porque es la primera sub capa pero esto
debería ser muy suave cuando pasamos del
litio al neón pero no lo es por lo que
debemos desarrollar un nuevo modelo que
consiste de capas y ahora sub capas y
esas capas se dividen en orbitales en
otras palabras por que la ionización
aumenta y luego cae es por el efecto de
blindaje del orbital 2s y el cambio que
tenemos aquí tiene que ver con la
repulsión entre electrones
nuevamente un modelo es una construcción
o interpretación teórica y mientras los
nuevos datos coincidan con el modelo los
seguiremos usando pero una vez que la
información nueva ya no coincide con el
modelo tendremos que desarrollar un
modelo nuevo lo que debiste aprender es
cómo determinar si la evidencia es
consistente con el modelo recordemos lo
que vimos aquí la información obtenida
de la energía de ionización no coincidió
con el modelo de board que teníamos por
lo que tuvimos que modificar y
probablemente tendremos que modificar
nuestro modelo actual en el futuro lo
que nos dará una mejor comprensión de lo
que es un átomo y como luce espero que
esto les haya sido útil